[Music]
a
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowlakes heads explode let me
be clear before this podcast begins we
are loud proud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
the rights of other people is not
Liberty you [__] eating [__] ah the
smell of freedom of speech this is the
Tony Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them I mean if you want to get excited
get excited right like if it gets you
all Juiced up
inside about this this pole business
whatever whatever it takes to get you
engaged whatever it takes to get
[Music]
motivated you must not trust the
polls you must trust action polls don't
vote people do people vote that's what
Today Show is about is getting engaged
in your democracy and getting engaged
with mockery and [__] is a great way
to get
engaged you know that's one of my
favorite ways to get engaged in your
democracy is [__] with these
people [__] with them we will and [__]
with them we
must and continue that's the only way to
beat these stupid bastards it really is
at their own
game I know it it feels like that might
not be the answer
immediately but if you haven't been
paying
attention since
2015 we've gotten better and better at
mockery and [__] as we learn on the
way and I say we I mean the pro
democracy
Coalition and that is the way that we
must win this democracy's next chance
because that's the thing folks with the
fascist right around the
corner with them installed in our
governments all over the country in
state governments and County governments
and school boards and the federal
government our democracy's at risk it
could be its last breath
but I'm very
confident because I believe the American
people know what democracy
means they know what it means not not
these [__] eaters are like we're not a
democracy we're
Republic we're a republic Tony don't you
know as if a republic can't be a
democracy it's really [__] I know
it's dumb I know
but these are the people who think
Taylor Swift is a scop and really
honestly the scop is [__]
working holy [__] is the scop working
isn't it oh man we couldn't have planned
it better we couldn't have planned it
better here at the antifa corporate
headquarters in Kami Falls Missouri
that's where we broadcast every single
weekday right here in Kami Falls
Missouri at the antifa corporate
headquarters we have a meeting
we had a meeting and we said hey you
know what let's do a scop with this
Taylor Swift stuff you know T who's she
you know what we'll do we'll make her
the [__] hottest pop store on the
planet right I mean absolutely the
greatest [__] pop artist that has
ever come on the scene will do that
because you know antifas it can do
anything right I mean we can rig
presidential elections we can't really
rig house elections otherwise we'd we'd
have a super majority in the house a
super majority in the Senate but you
know all superpowers only go so far but
we did we made Taylor Swift an absolute
pop star here at the antifa headquarters
antifa did that we did she it's not her
it was none of her doing right it's not
because she's talented or beautiful it's
not because she's a decent person it's
because antifa made her very [__]
famous that's all it is we actually us
at the antifa headquarters we we had a
meeting about the Kansas City Chiefs CU
it is in Kami Falls Missouri so you know
it does make sense this this this
conspiracy does make sense and I'm I'm
kind of letting it all out of the bag
here you know kind of pulling back the
curtain to show you what's behind the
curtain of Taylor
Swift but doesn't it make sense that the
antifa corporate headquarters is in Kami
Falls
Missourri and the Kansas City Chiefs who
who are in Kansas City
Missouri would it make sense if we use
them maybe what we would do is we'd get
one of the best coaches in the league we
get one of the best quarterbacks in the
league oh yeah we we would draft him and
we would groom him we would we would
make him win Super Bowls for several
years him and Travis Kelce and just make
sure that Travis Kelce stayed single
long enough that we could introduce him
to our pop star that we created
antifa introduce them and make them fall
in
love oh it's all part of the big plan
all part of the big plan just to make
sure that sleepy Joe Biden who can't
even put on his shoes becomes the
president of the United States in
2024 I mean it had nothing to do with
2020 right
like we we were really laying in wait
for Joe Biden's reelection here with
this with this scop and boy is it
[__] working oh my God is it is our
plan is in full swing let me let me give
you a little hint oh my you're gonna
love this you're gonna love this we had
a big meeting a big meeting about this
year's Super Bowl we're like wouldn't it
be awesome wouldn't it be
awesome if the Chiefs weren't even
weren't even first and then they came
back like a Cinderella story in the
[__] playoffs Patrick mom wins his
very first away playoff game that would
be a great story and what we would do is
force we would force our created antifa
pop star Taylor Swift to go to every
single one of these games and we would
make her make her look like she was
cheering on the
Chiefs I mean obviously she's not a real
cheese fan this is all made up it's all
a scop folks I mean why would why would
she go cheer on Travis Kelce we're the
ones who introduced them they're not
actually in love this all make believe
it's all prend this is all to get Joe
Biden elected
folks don't you know
this and it's working beautifully we had
all these football teams throw these
games the antifa had I'm telling you we
had the NFL here at the antifa corporate
headquarters with us here working with
us making sure that the queer beer budl
and
fizer were the sponsors of this they're
the on who oh man they fronted all the
cash for all this
[__] it's the greatest it's the
greatest story of [__] there
absolutely
is and this scop is working perfectly
and now and now that this scop is in
full swing we can we can we can pull
back the curtain and make it all
transparent that's right our goal the
entire time was to make the entire incel
white fragile male right
wing absolutely lose their Minds about
Taylor
Swift make Taylor Swift live rentree
inside their little [__] closeted
skulls and they can't stop talking about
her it's perfect our plan worked
perfectly and the reason why is because
no one really would pay attention to
this stuff if it weren't for us if it
weren't for us getting the right-wing
idiots mad about Taylor Swift they
wouldn't be paying attention to politics
they wouldn't be paying attention to
this presidential election
I mean imagine if the right Wingers we
wouldn't have baited
them into talking about Taylor Swift
everyone like a Taylor and Travis oh
they're so cute and everyone would have
moved on the swifties would have watched
and this was the this was our sell to
the NFL I'm telling you I was in the
room I was the main I was the main pitch
person here when I was pitching this to
the NFL I'm like look listen I know I
know it sounds crazy that we're going to
do all this just to get Joe Biden
elected but here's the thing here's how
it's great for the
NFL you're going to get millions of
swifties to watch your football game for
just the itty bitty tiny winny seconds
that Taylor Swift will appear on your
cameras 30 seconds 40 seconds hell we'll
make it 20 seconds 20 seconds a game you
show Taylor Swift and millions of people
will watch your football game and you
can sell them queer beer and fizer all
day long it'll be fantastic they'll buy
so much fizer and so much queer
beer that your your advertisers can't
stop giving you
money I mean that's how you really get
the NFL involved in this scop you know
what I mean that's I mean you got to
attract them with mountains of
cash I mean this is all part of the plan
okay it's all part of the plan all
right and the scop is working
fantastically and the reason why is
because for the next two weeks the right
Wingers won't say anything but Taylor
Swift's
name all it does is put pop culture out
there into the world and people start
talking about this election you see do
you see how he did it do you see we took
two two pieces of Pop Culture football
and Taylor Swift we made him [__]
have a
baby we made him [__] have a baby and
right that's one thing the right-wing
does not
like the right-wing does not like
hypothetical babies they want real
forced birth okay they don't like that
antifa hypothetical theoretical birth
they want real forced birth okay and we
knew that we knew that the whole time we
knew we knew that's all they would do
and yell and scream and yell and scream
and this scop is working so beautifully
because now people in the country are
paying attention to the presidential
election ction which brings me to the
next part of the scop the next part of
the scop is to rig the polls that's
right to rig the polls to make it look
like Joe Biden's winning just to make
just to get the right Wingers absolutely
terrified to make sure they understand
that our Taylor Swift
scop is successful because they got to
have the proof the proofs in the puting
and in the polls isn't it so ever since
Taylor Swift has come on the scene Joe
Biden has risen and risen and risen in
the polls now we rig all these polls
they're all rigged they're all rigged
here at the antifa corporate
headquarters
okay and they're gonna believe every
single bit of this scop even though all
of it's fake Taylor's not really a very
good pop artist she's not really that
pretty she's not talented at all neither
is Travis Kelce or Patrick Mahomes or
the Kansas City Chiefs for crying out
loud we made all that up we got all
those people to do all those things just
so Joe Biden can get
elected you know what now that I think
about it what we should have done what
we should have done is just getting
people to engage in their democracy
maybe instead of wasting all that time
coming up with this Taylor Swift scop
and all the energy and money and time we
spent to get the Taylor Swift scop off
the ground maybe what we should have
done
is we should have just I don't know took
our strategic
outrage our Fury against
fascism of a bunch of America First
Republican Nazis taking away our rights
and our neighbors rights our mother's
rights our sister's rights our wife's
rights our daughter's
rights our neighbors the lgbtq community
our neighbors in our
community taking away their rights
trying to demonize trans children to
strip away parental consent in this
country forcing forcing our children to
be Christians in the schools in
Oklahoma taking away parental consent of
what books your children can and can't
read maybe if we focused a little more
in h now that I'm thinking about it you
know I know this scop thing is working
really well I know it's going
swimmingly and the rightwing can't shut
the [__] up about Taylor
Swift maybe just maybe if we would to
spent all that time and all that energy
on engaging people in their democracy
maybe just maybe we could win this
election
easily fair and
square that's a 15-minute story for you
I don't know go share it around I don't
give a [__] go tell these people that
yeah Tony playing this whole goddamn
thing hell I'm the one with the Swifty
AI machine even the left is pissed off
at me about it do I care [__] no I don't
care but that's the point is I do care
about our democracy because I know that
we aren't going to be able to do this
kind of [__] and mockery if we don't
have
democracy so don't believe the [__]
polls okay don't believe the hype about
Taylor Swift just talk about it just
talk about it I'm telling you you tell
your neighbors and your friends even the
ones who support Trump and have voted
for Trump they're going to believe that
the Taylor Swift stuff is a bunch of
[__] that they cannot believe that a
bunch of people all around the country
are whining and crying and
bitching that Taylor Swift is [__]
Travis Kelce and Travis Kelce won
football games to go to the Super
Bowl let's get them to talk about it
let's get the country to have the
conversation you think it's going to be
easy to get the country to to talk about
data around healthc care
huh you think it's going to be easy to
get the country to talk about the
inflation
rate do you do you think it's going to
be easy to get people to talk about the
stock how high the stock market is and
why it's so high huh you think that's
going to be easy no that ain't G to be
easy
they'll talk about the [__] Super
Bowl
though oh [__] they'll talk about the
Super Bowl they're going to have Super
Bowl parties even people who don't even
watch [__] football are going to go
to Super Bowl
parties people who don't know any Taylor
Swift's music even if they [__] heard
it are going to go to Super Bowl parties
and gonna see Taylor Swift right there
on the
screen not for very long 20 30 40
seconds maybe maybe 60 seconds if the
swifties are
lucky but it's a way to get engaged it's
a way to talk about the presidential
election I mean all you got to do is say
did you hear how all these white these
fragile white men all around the country
these Trump supporting white men are
Furious that Taylor Swift is dating
Travis Kelce and they think it's some
crazy
scop even this wild crazy guy in commi
Falls Missouri says yeah it's an antifa
yeah yeah it's an antifa s you godamn
right it
is fine by me use those words I just
said cut them clip them say look look
the commies the commies are committing a
Taylor Swift scop I don't give a [__] go
for
it but the thing you should be doing is
making sure that the the words that are
leaving your lipss right now when you're
talking about this election is Taylor
Swift Taylor Swift doesn't have to do a
goddamn thing at this point the
right-wing has done it all for
us all of it they've laid it all at our
feet and these polls with again don't
believe the [__] polls it's all
[__]
anyways am I saying that Joe Biden ain't
winning no but don't believe that [__]
stop believing it just because it might
be true doesn't mean that the polls are
real and that they they don't suck
because they suck they suck the polls
suck trust your
instinct trust your
action that's what you must do and you
must use your strategic outrage to
engage in your
democracy and one way over the next two
weeks that is going to be crucial to
engage in your democracy because folks
Donald Trump's going to March down to
South Carolina he's going to beat the
[__] [__] out of Nikki Haley in South
Carolina and that's it it's
done and if you're not doing
math South Carolina is directly after
the Super
Bowl directly after
it right after the entire country just
had a conversation about how well I mean
is it really that big of a deal that
Taylor Swift endorses Joe Biden because
is didn't she do that before I mean and
why are you so [__] been out of shape
that she's at a football game oh because
women will go vote with
her did you see that Liz Cheney supports
Taylor
Swift everyone's like oh good on Liz
Cheney I'm like [__] Liz Cheney Liz hey
Liz if you're listening of this let me
tell you something Taylor Swift would
make sure to engage her entire fan base
to go vote against you because you vote
against women's rights you [__]
[__] [__] Liz Cheney we don't we
listen I I know it's G to be popular for
these [__]
scumbags to try to appropriate our
movements against Donald
Trump for democracy but Liz Cheney is no
friend of democracy she's no friend of
women's rights this is this stupid [__]
would stand stand in front of a
microphone today and say the Democrats
are trying to kill babies after they're
born she said it before she'll say it
again and she's saying it because it's
not because it's the truth she knows
it's a lie to take away women's rights
and Taylor would stand up against that
[__] just like she would stand up
against Marsha birdest
Blackburn no matter how much Blackburn
said good about her [__] that
[__] now she ain't G to say it like I'm
going to say it you know it's Taylor
Swift I get it but maybe if I use the
Swifty AI machine to give you a little
dose of Taylor Swift you know all hopped
up on Tony Michaels well let's do
that oh Tony that you can't do that oh
my God that's what they're gonna do oh
really
well that's the weapon they're going to
use okay then now I know now I know what
weapon to use against them
folks we got a [__] democra democracy
to save
here do you really care who wins the
Super Bowl when it's all over with I
mean alls I want is in 2024 for
democracy win so we keep having Super
Bowls that would be nice I mean I I like
to go to Super Bowl parties you know
what I mean hang out with my friends
drink a little bit eat meat and cheese
tray [__] chips and salsa right maybe a
little bit of
pizza
summer sausage cheese Ritz crackers you
know what I'm talking about the queso
dip
right have a little queer beer maybe
maybe we'll have a fizer buffet at these
Super Bowl
parties but I would like to have
democracy to continue so we can continue
to do these
things we really do not appreciate the
way of life that we have created in this
country
and the way of life that we can deliver
for all people who come to this
country and want to be part of the
American
experiment and by God if that means I
got to pretend for just a couple [__]
weeks and maybe a couple weeks after
that because they're not going to just
talk about this till the Super
Bowl I mean as long as Taylor Swift gets
one minute 60 [__] seconds on the TV
during the Super Bowl they're gonna talk
about it for at least two months
remember how long they talked about the
Eminem not wearing sexy boots do you
remember that they're gonna boycott
Eminem and [__] Eminem That Eminem
should be sexy I've been jerking off to
that em in for years and now she's she's
not GNA be sexy anymore you remember
that Tucker Carlson you remember that
[__] you remember when they found out
that gay people drink beer oh my god
when the LGBT you me is like yeah we
drink beer and we love Bud Light what
the [__] are you talking about they're
like Bud light's gay drink
buttweiser that's the same thing it's
the same [__]
beer go drink coer light and everyone's
like that's that's gayer than Bud Light
what are you K's light is the gayest of
beers they're definitely going to talk
about Taylor swifter two [__] months
after the Super Bowl so we got the way
I'm figuring it we got 10 weeks maybe 12
we got 12 weeks to pretend that Taylor
Swift was all our idea the whole
time and Taylor
Swift definitely 100% has been a a dark
Brandon scop for at least 12 years maybe
14 16 years is how long we've been
working this dark Brandon
scop let them [__] believe it let the
country talk about it let them say dumb
[__] I'm telling you there is no better
way to get people to talk about the
presidential election that would never
even think about the presidential
election until maybe a couple days
before they
vote and by God if we can Court them to
the right side now that's a lot less
work we got to do during the summer and
the fall leading up into November we can
find more of those votes in other ways
to
engage people make decisions on
elections at all kinds of
points and again polls don't vote people
do people [__] vote and I hope they
keep talking about Taylor Swift all the
way to November [__] there' be nothing
better than
that so don't believe the [__] poll
stop listening to the [__] media what
they're telling you and not telling you
because today they're telling you Joe
Biden's winning next month when when
when Trump marches through super Tuesday
and he's not going to go to criminal
trial he'll be winning they'll be like
oh my God the Earth is falling apart Joe
Biden's gonna lose Joe Biden's old and
he's
decrepit blah blah blah Yaky
schacky and it would be the same race
that it was the day
before so it's time for for you to use
your strategic outrage in whatever form
of [__] you
can even if that form of [__] doesn't
seem like being pissed
off just have a conversation about
Taylor Swift with people did you see did
you see what these [__] weirdos on
the internet are saying about Taylor
Swift I mean I know they can't get
[__] but holy [__] they should get
[__]
it ain't no wonder it ain't no wonder
all them guys out there named Brendan
can't get [__] Jesus Christ if they
keep talking like that they'll never be
with a goddamn
woman I'm telling you folks mockery is
the best
tool mockery is the best tool make them
make their decision
now at the Super Bowl
party and I know you feel like ah Tony
that's probably not the way it works
that's exactly the way it
works it's
exactly the way it
works so
engage however and whenever you can over
the next two weeks and probably eight
weeks beyond that at least at a bare
minimum at a bare
minimum because they definitely they
definitely will have Taylor Swift living
rentree inside their brains that 60
seconds where she's cheering her
boyfriend who is playing in the Super
he's the starting tight end the dude
catches touchdown passes at a football
game called the Super Bowl I don't know
if you know anything about the sports
ball or not but that's like the biggest
game ever and when you've been there
like five times in a row and you're
catching touchdown passes people who
love you are gonna kind of get excited
that's probably how it's gonna
work but that's what the way antifa
planned it the entire
time don't go anywhere we'll be right
back from the antia corporate
headquarters in Kami Falls
Missouri right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you ready for best pizza of
Life bring friends down to pepperoni hug
spot our chefs make pizza with heart and
Special Touch cheese pepperoni vegetable
and more secret things need delivery
pizzas come fast knock knock who's there
pizza Magic
eat pepperoni hugs spot Pizza your tummy
say thank you your mouth say m pepperoni
hugs spot it's like family but with more
cheese catch Tony's twitch stream the
[__] list Roundup at
twitch.tv/ thee Tony Michaels we're back
to the king of Brilliance this is the
Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast John G says here he says godamn
Swift is a boring subject I I know it's
boring I know I know it's going to bore
the [__] out of you and you're going to
get tired of talking about Taylor Swift
and you're going to have to go listen to
a few songs and all that [__] but listen
to me when I tell you this there is no
better point there is no better
positioning that our democracy needs
than a conversation about how the
right-wing inels are absolutely losing
their minds because they can't [__]
someone like Taylor Swift and they want
to elect Donald Trump because they can't
get
laid they can't get laid so they want
elect Donald Trump will definitely Force
women to [__] them he 100% he's going to
be dictator for a day and for that one
day he will force all women to [__] in
sales it'll happen and I'll finally get
laid I'll finally get me a piece of
ass that's probably what they think I
don't know if it's actually what they
think but go tell people that's what
they think go say that to people [__]
even if you got to just clip that video
on me saying It Go show it to him go
show it to him because mockery is the
best form of
[__] and [__] is how we're going
to win this election and I know the next
guy the guy we got on on Thursday clip
Sher knows that better than anyone else
he really does he's here for the [__]
and the [__] alone I think I think he
is clip how are you my friend I am doing
great as is the
[__] is that why you're is that why
you come on the Tony Michaels podcast is
for [__] only is it I I know you I
know you clip and put put all the
[__] that we create here just out of
couple reasons you know it's the [__]
I want to hear that cool Missouri accent
Missouri Missouri I say it I say it like
I'm from the hood right the hood of
Missouri before anybody starts
[__] um the oarks is what I was
getting at um and uh now I'm here
because it's actually a Ive and fun
conversation where we're not held back
by the constraints of many places and
can just tell the truth about who these
right-wing fuckwads are I think I think
that's an appropriate description of it
that we just you know and I I want I
wanted to with this show create a space
for that um that no one could [__] with
it no one could really say you can't say
that you can't say this that's offensive
Tony or wow that Tony he's crazy he's
like a circus clown yeah that's the
whole point like you you go you go to
the circus to watch the clowns you go to
the rodeo because the rodeo clowns are
kind of cool right they look kind of
cool and they're like [__] with the
bull and the Bull's all [__] pissed
off and they're just distracting the
bull while the cowbo I thought you just
went to the Circuit because you wanted
to see them beat on the animals because
you're a sick
bastard damn I'm not being serious um
thankfully the hey man we got four cats
so nobody's challenged me for Love For
Animals I spend half my week in cat [__]
cleaning it up okay well that's that's
love right
that is love that's how much we love our
furry guys and we love all animals and
and uh the way the circus used to treat
them I'm glad that [__] got shut down
seems like now they've kind of reopened
something and they're no longer doing
what I would say is a to torturing
animals so let's go let's go with Rodeo
let's go with rodeo clowns then yeah
instead of the circus we'll we'll we'll
use that you can go with whatever you'd
like to call you know you know I you
know I will I I don't get and I will I
will
abide
So Yesterday um I played a clip because
what's funny is all these right- Wingers
are losing their minds and it feels like
to me because Marsha birdes Blackburn is
from Tennessee where Taylor Swift is a
resident she lives in Nashville and a
lot of people are like why does she live
in Nashville Tennessee because they
don't know what the [__] Nashville is I
don't know that they don't know that's
like the mecca of country music and
that's how that what genre started Beau
place in the middle of this big large
hole of
diarrhea I'm kidding there are a bunch
of nice parts of Tennessee Tennessee is
beautiful Tennessee is beautiful it's
more the the usual I I've got it here in
Cincinnati it's not glamorous like
Nashville but when you live in the city
you know in that Trump leaning Tennessee
is a lot more Trump leaning than us but
even our we're a little Trump leaning
State you you get all the people outside
hate you because you're the ones with
common sense who vote for the people
that don't want to destroy the
Constitution so I get it they don't what
you libtard you libtard in your
Constitution for crying out for gosh
darn thing so much with articles of the
Confederacy work just right right we're
not a democracy or Republic which I kind
of want to talk to you about with this
Marsha Blackburn because this clip of
her and I can play it um but the
audience has already seen it where
Marshall Blackburn just is kissing
Taylor Swift's ass did you see this well
Taylor let me say quickly when Taylor
Swift went after Trump a couple years
ago in that video with her parents
backstage at a show or wherever it was
that went viral she also went after
Marsha Blackburn and I think she
actually has Marsha Blackburn scared
because there's no other way I hate to
say it or very few other ways like we
can pull a Doug Jones if the Republican
candidate's molesting somebody right and
win in a place like Alabama or Tennessee
otherwise it's almost impossible but the
one thing that can overcome that and
this is why they're so freaked out is
that Taylor Swift has as much of a cult
following I would say on POS in a
positive way based on love and
acceptance and that kind of thing but
she has much of a devoted following As
Trump except for it's much bigger right
and so they are scared of that they are
and and Marsha particularly because if
there's if there is something that can
get can beat her as you call bird nest
uh what I don't know what that bird nest
Blackburn yeah that thing on her head
whatever that thing is anybody you know
do you I'll say quickly do you ever see
the old uh Marsha Blackburn like like
the the ad she did like 40 years ago
when she was an image consultant no huh
how she started she was wait wait wait
she was an image consultant find it
online it's hilarious first of all it
speaks to our Senate that an image
consultant is a Republican senator but B
that did I say one and B now I'm being a
republican but but but my second point
is um if she's an image consultant she
ever look in the mirror at that thing on
her head and just be like hey uh I'm not
trying to to create nesting ground for
Robins I'm just trying to have something
cover my my my head maybe I should do
something differently I don't
know well let's see if she can do
something differently in this she's all
combed there look well easy easy easy
this just might be the greatest hair day
she's ever had it's still kind of shitty
but let's let's let's listen to how Mara
kisses Taylor's ass a lot of time in
your home state of Tennessee even though
she was born in Mississippi Newsweek had
a poll yesterday I love that first off
she was Bor born in Mississippi yeah a
lot of people were born in a lot of
states and they moved somewhere else and
the reason why she spends a lot of time
in Tennessee is because uh she [__]
lives there what the what I mean people
they try every little stupid trick shame
of it is it works with a lot of these
people because these people are so dumb
well she just came and carpet bagged her
way in across the border from Alabama to
Tennessee and we're not having that here
in as the news sits in New York the news
guy sits in New York exactly like come
on man like he's in Tennessee or some
[__] but somebody I'll speak for
somebody who grew up in New York City I
want all these [__] from Fox who
aren't actually from New York City to
leave right now right they're not New
Yorkers leave right well here let's
listen to this fake New Yorker talk
about how Taylor Swift is a fake
Tennessean and then let's watch the US
senator from Tennessee absolutely kissed
Taylor's ass that found that 18% of vot
voters would actually vote for whoever
Taylor Swift told them to vote for in
2020 in a documentary she said that you
were Donald Trump in a wig how do you
resp shitty wig a shitty wig your take
on the impact she
could in November Taylor Swift is really
a popular very talented young woman she
has built quite an Empire I am please
don't destroy
my that she has chosen to base that in
Nash Bill she is considered to be an
influencer I think when it she is
considered 95 million followers on
Twitter I don't know how how is she
considered to be an influencer right I
mean well hey hey hey there's a lot of
bars here okay cliff and one of the bars
is that you have to have at least a
hundred million people that follow you
on Twitter before you're considered an
influencer okay know [__] I thought I
when I pass 60,000 followers on Twitter
I was an influencer but I got I got a
long [__] way to go
man uh I'm gonna look up the most
followed accounts on Twitter well Elon
is probably one of them but he half of
his are like fake so remember well right
I mean that well right I mean you gotta
you gotta make sure if you own somebody
did one of those like Audits and found
that something like maybe 60% or
something were real like it's so let's
see if we can uh see where Taylor Swift
Falls here uh um I don't want to agree
to any of that I just want the [__]
numbers okay let's see Kim Kardashian
has 75 million okay um NASA NASA has 78
million followers that's impressive
actually that is YouTube YouTube here
has almost 80 million okay okay now the
number 10 is Lady Gaga now Lady Gaga is
a very big pop star in and of herself
and really I'm surprised these idiots
aren't saying Lady Gaga is
a her and I'm surprised she hasn't
spoken out more she probably will more
towards the election because obviously
she has liberal politics too right um
Donald Trump comes in at number nine at
87.4 his are like fake too so I'm not
just saying that by by the way about
everybody I don't like um people do you
know you can do these audits of what you
know looks like Bots and whatever and
again it's not to say Trump doesn't have
a lot of followers he does he has a ton
because if he has 40 million that's
still a lot of really [__] dumb
people but he's he's DB a lot of that's
fake but go ahead um India's Prime
Minister Modi has 93.4 million at number
eight number seven is the scop herself
the scop pop star herself Taylor Swift
has 94.8 so almost 95 million followers
the only ones in front of Taylor Swift
is Katy Perry
Rihanna uh chiso Ronaldo who the [__] is
in icer player okay just one of two best
in the
world the last 20 years he's probably a
Scamp too um Justin Bieber Barack Obama
Barack Obama our Manchurian Candidate we
know from our Manchurian Candidate from
Kenya you know that that guy bar like
about Barack Obama is that they had the
foresight uh knowing that he was going
to eventually be president to when he
was born create a fake birth certificate
in Hawaii right they could see like 45
years in the future and they knew that
he was going to run and that they had to
pretend he was an American citizen so I
really I do appreciate that they were
able to pull all thatp us here at the
antifa headquarters here in Kami Falls
Missouri we come up with all these scops
we've been doing this for many many
decades okay well you have the DeLorean
right so you could see what was going to
happen come do we have the DeLorean
Absolut I mean we got something better
than a [__] DeLorean I've got I've
got a piece of [__] Tesla that's all
dressed up as a goddamn as a goddamn
time machine I mean you know if you're
going to get a sh if you're G to get a
shitty Machinery that thing looks like a
dishwasher on Wheels is what it looks
like yeah well you know it's you
remember the um the Aztec the Pontiac
Aztec you remember that piece of [__]
yeah it looks like you took a DeLorean
and an Aztec they [__] and had a baby
and it's and it's the Cyber truck now we
go more with like my washing machine and
my dishwasher uh you know they they they
had a little of a humping session and
out came the [__] cyber truck I think
the Cyber truck has a pots and pan cycle
I think it does I mean I think it I
think it's a little I hope it has like
you know yeah I hope it has that speed
cycle right right right a lot of the
people that would buy it are probably
incels that need that speed cycle to you
know really Jazz up their day right well
so what do you think do you think it
pisses um pisses trumpers off that the
the uh the Kenyan scop Barack Obama and
the pop star scop are both have more
followers than Donald Trump do you think
that really piss oh my God I mean dude
trumpism is literally built on looking
at everybody who's better than you which
in their cases is most people and hating
the world for it the entire the entire
all of the the foundation of trumpism I
mean the guy ran for president
originally because Barack Obama made fun
of him you know at that at that press
Gathering the the the grid iron dinner
thing and everybody was laughing at
Trump because because Obama was mocking
him for having to make difficult
decisions like whether to kick Snookie
off of uh you know reality uh his stupid
reality show and that led him he was he
could not stand that the black guy who
is who is better looking has much more
class who is successful who's like
Harvard Law review president and you
know I go on and on you know and here's
this trashy guy who's handed $400
million and again I I always feel a need
to say this bankrupted a [__] Casino
again it is a place where you hand over
money to people they pump oxygen in give
you free drinks don't have any Windows
to disorient you so you know or clocks
so you know what time it is so you just
sit there and keep handing over your
money he [__] bankrupted it like no
nobody can do that no there is one part
you remember the scene in home alone 2o
cuz he's always talking about home alone
too right I'm in home alone 2o I'm in
home alone too I'm so famous I'm in home
alone too now in Home Alone 2 there is a
scene where Marv and Harry are at the
ice rink and and and and Marv comes over
to Harry and and they're trying to
scheme on how they're going to steal
money during Christmas
right and they they want to knock up a
candy store like no no no that
five-year-olds knock up a candy store
we're going to we're going to loot a toy
store and someone says no one's no one's
dumb up to knock up a toy star on
Christmas Eve oh yeah there is me and
you like that reminds me of like ma all
the time like no one's dumb enough to
support a guy who [__] bankrupt a
casino oh yeah there is me and you buddy
me a key part of that story I feel it
that hasn't been told enough is one time
Matt Davon was being interviewed uh
about the the whole thing with Trump um
and he said that that what Trump would
do is when he owned the prop property
and all his current properties are of
course bed bug infested uh with you know
syphilis breaking out nobody wants to go
anywhere near them but but but he used
to own the plaza which obviously is a
landmark in the in in New York and
people go to and so he in every contract
where someone would use a property of
his he would make them sign in the
contract that he would get to make a
cameo in it and what Matt Damon said is
because Matt Damon filmed a movie in one
of the Trump properties I can't remember
what it was and he's like it was a joke
he's like we everybody would go and let
it we'd let it we'd sign that thing sure
you're going to be in it and then as
soon as we got to to the the you know
the postop part of it where we were
sitting there editing we just cut his
scene out yeah right because they get
the they get the intellectual ability to
cut him out of the scene so but they
were like he's like I don't know why the
[__] they didn't do that in Home Alone
too like somebody must have forgotten
they left it
in story that Matt Damon told about that
whole thing the reason why he even
appeared in that movie um he's tried to
appear in at least 30 or 40 and you can
figure out the percentages yourself
every single other one is cut his seat I
feel like we're going to do that in
November what you just described right
like we're gonna we're all pretending
that yeah he's running for president
he's got a chance to win oh man and then
we're gonna just G cut him out at the
very end like everyone's going to go
[__] vote against him there's gonna
be mountains of votes against him and
then we're just going to cut him out of
the whole thing like haha [__] we
fooled you I mean look I would take the
final result being certified by one vote
if that's what it takes right so you
know but the happiness the pure joy if
he were to get the living [__] kicked
out of him and lose not just you know
Arizona and Georgia and Michigan and
like the swing States like that but the
ones that have leaned a little
Republican lately my State Ohio and
Florida and Texas and just in the kind
of ass kicking where he only wins the 10
to like 14 almost completely rural
States and gets the [__] kicked out of
them everywhere else because all these
people that won't vote for him because
he's at that point a convicted criminal
which I believe he will be uh multiple
times by the time we get there and and
various other things that he does along
the way and whatever I mean it would
just be you know and then we end up
winning holding on to the Senate because
we win a couple of those key seats win
the house in a huge way I mean that kind
of a night could do a lot for our
democracy so well here is here is a
Biden's supposed lead now polls don't
vote and people really should not take
these polls too seriously I mean if it
get you hyped up and it gets you excited
to get engaged in your democracy you
know whatever cool that's fine yeah I
don't I don't give a sh whatever's got
to get you all fired up to go engage in
your democracy if it's some dumbass pole
fine let it be that but the point that
I'm trying to make here is that um the
Taylor Swift scop is working because
Biden that's the good thing right is
it's probably freaking them the [__] out
and you you well let me ask you because
I I don't take much I don't take poll
seriously at all like I I actually think
we shouldn't have uh the media saying
anything about polls because it just
it's [__] horse race C well I mean
they can they can be rigged they're not
they're Antiquated in how they actually
take the polls nowadays they're not
calling cell phones a lot of time a lot
of younger folks aren't answering I mean
I can just give you very quickly like I
don't take any of them seriously and I
think they're mostly [__] and I
started my career off in politics
working and polling but we're in a
different age now and I don't think a
lot of polling firms have adjusted and I
think there are some ways you simply
can't adjust because it's harder to find
people because people are are sort of in
so many different channels and so many
different places to find enough people
to to to get a representative sample uh
my representative sample is talking to
all sorts of people I know who are
Republicans I mean the kinds of people
that voted for Trump once or twice and
to a person almost having them these are
people that that weren't scared to tell
me back then saying that either they're
voting for Biden or not voting at all
because they can't bring themselves and
again we'll have to see but you know
what if it were just my anecdotal
evidence I'd be like yeah yeah but exit
polling I trust a little bit more
because they're getting people coming
out as opposed to like all these weird
places they get them on they're getting
people that actually showed up to vote
and again the exit poll that I'm gonna
keep going to I think it was even higher
in New Hampshire in Iowa was in this
white Evangelical place was 43% of Nikki
Haley voters saying they'd vote for
Biden over Trump so so I I don't the but
regular media run polls like that like
if people think that I'm a hypocrite
because I always dismiss the ones that
show Trump head and now and think I'm
now like oh my God Biden six points
ahead yeah that's real no I don't take
that [__] thing seriously at all it's
just I'm happy about it because I know
it's freaking the people on the right
out who do take it seriously right and
again like I have a whole part of my
YouTube channel like we may have to
create a whole division which is just
devoted to uh loser right-wing incel
Pencil Neck Geeks Who hate uh Taylor
Swift because she's more talented
smarter just better at everything than
they are and they cannot [__] handle
it and they realize they're vulnerable
because she has got such a rabid
following in a number of states where it
could be close they are they are
vulnerable as hell to her flipping an
election away from them well I I agree
with that polls are Antiquated and and
and we're in living in a different time
and really you shouldn't pay attention
to him at all but if it if if really
pretending that the polls are real just
pretend you know because I'll pretend
like yeah these polls are awesome the
Taylor Swift scop is working I if I
gotta pretend that for just a couple
minutes in front of these [__] to get
them all round up yeah [__] them yeah I
mean we're all down for [__] we are
all down for [__] at this point so it
doesn't matter um but I W to I want to
show you a little bit more it leads to
like Tim P peeing his pants on on
Twitter that's entirely worth it as far
as I'm concerned right but I want to
show you the reason why I don't actually
think um I mean I'm going to pretend
that it's the Taylor Swift thing but I
think it's something else that the
country is actually paying attention to
and this is the Republican's fault
because really people and and when I say
this I want to say this that this is
just my feeling but it's an absolute
fact almost the majority of the country
in this country don't give a [__] about
the Border they don't give a [__] about
it they don't care they don't they don't
listen they don't give a [__] they care
more about the price of gas than they
care about [__] the Border hardcore
trumpers who are who who get all the
emails and watch Fox News and listen to
their stupid talk radio people they're
the only ones who care about you're
right because everybody else I mean this
is just politics 101 I mean you can get
people to fear certain things yes you
can get people uh you can move them in
certain ways but unless it's something
they're experiencing dayto day it is a
lot harder to do that you know it has to
be something where they know people
where they feel it themselves and you
pointed out with gas a lot of of of moms
worried with their daughters because of
abortion rights and what could happen to
them I mean these are you know parents
sending their kids to school and
realizing that Republicans have fought
harder for you know to keep the AR-15
legal and they have for Ukraine I mean
or for a book they ility to to murder
children in schools and get rid of books
ban books but not guns right like these
are things I mean again because I have
kids they're at school these are things
I think about right and and I think a
lot of this is where a lot of people are
so yeah I'm not they're not thinking of
some abstract like oh well unless you
maybe live near there in Texas or
Arizona maybe it's an issue then that
that you're you're seeing a lot about
and is crossing your mind but if you
live where you or I do like I the border
the border is a bazillion miles away
right here gives a [__] well so here's
the thing is that not only did the
rightwing Deliver us a great [__]
weapon to win this election with Taylor
Swift and their little scop conspiracy
theory because that's fantastic they
they like they like did a number for us
that's a that's a huge gift the other
gift that they gave us was them yelling
and screaming about the border the other
gift that they gave us that I don't
think we really saw at the time because
it's kind of vile and inhumane to put
migrants on buses and on planes and ship
them places that they don't know you're
sending exactly just just a little bit
inhumane right but but what happened was
is the country started to go hey the
Republicans are screaming about the
Border what the hell is this and they're
like yeah we need to fix the border and
then they're like no we can't fix the
Border because we want Donald Trump to
get elected you want to run on a
something that we can say is broken and
destroyed and yeah well let's listen to
Rick Scott say it here by the way can't
pass a bill that possibly would make it
harder for Trump to do his job well you
know that's what the language is going
to be this is how it's always written
and it was written by Schumer's people I
understand trump it do his job is that
Rick Scott or is that one of the Men in
Black aliens I'm not really sure you
know I think I think um Rick Scott is
actually you know they said there was
aliens the government found aliens and
[__] and I actually think we probably
did find aliens and it's if you and if
you look at people who most likely to be
I mean Rick Scott does not look human
let's all be honest here look human I
don't think he is I don't I think it's
confirmed Cliff I don't think he
actually we easily find some weird [__]
like he has three hearts or you
know who was that group The oh yeah
that's right from men black we should
test out and see if he's a BAL
chinian well the ballchinians he he's
like punches them in the chin because
they've got well I mean Trump kind of
has a vagina vagina neck so I don't know
those are related to the bans or you
showed on on your show here the fold
right did you see the thing on Twitter
where somebody showed it and it got it
got censored for being um for yeah
sexual for being sexual material yeah it
looks like it looks like a [__] I mean
that's what it looks like it looks like
porn it looks like [__] porn if
that's not hilarious yeah it looks it
looks like a closeup picture of a you
know Poss
is that Twitter just smelled him well
that could be that could be the other
thing when you want to say what's going
on if polls really are now now clip now
wait a second wait a second let's back
up I want to apologize because I we're
definitely not saying that all all
genitalia that would might be that way
smells like Donald Trump I know I mean I
like to offend people but right I wasn't
talking about that though
dude first of all ah
I was talking about his other problem oh
oh okay all right all right all right I
see from iing from neck to bottom I was
I was talking about his his neck jiner
at the moment so I don't know that thing
smells but it's probably pretty
sweaty I mean and I I surmised on the
show that day that that's where he keeps
his collection of Putin's come so I mean
that
that's um speaking I was I was positing
that that there was Iranian nuclear
secrets you know it's not quite as gross
as yours but um right I think that that
when we can't find where all these
secrets went I think come on mine's way
more accurate than yours mine's way more
accur got an additional what you'd call
prison
wallet it's in his neck right all right
speaking of uh speaking of non here is
um this this Republican but MTZ is here
to back him up on how the Republicans
can't tell the truth about the Border
let's listen Ching not to and that is a
big part of the problem here yeah and
Jake by the way the speaker said no
because Donald Trump said no the speaker
is Donald Trump's no boy okay on this
subject look I'll give Republicans
credit for a second they have been high
okay so I come up with um this new
nickname u based on mt's little noboy
comment here noboy Johnson is kind of a
good nickname noboy Johnson noboy
Johnson I think that's his his password
to get into his porn monitor when he
wants his kids porn it's it's no boy
John but you know what's funny about
that clip that I really enjoy it's um
and I didn't even see the dude talk for
very long but every time I see him that
little sort of bearded weirdo uh hey hey
easy on bearded weirdos okay easy on
bearded weirdo dude your beard looks
cool his beard looks like he ran into a
a thorn bush and and it got okay
any so um and half the time I've got one
too so beards are good just not on him
um he is in you know one of the the
districts that's like right next to
Santos's right the New York Democratic
party [__] up in Epic Ways last cycle
and found a way to lose three four seats
that were lean Democratic or swing seats
that guy is terrible on everything
except for all the things because he's
scared for his political life so he was
like don't touch George Sandos but then
when SOS we start getting close to the
election he was the one that got up and
was like throw him out get R SOS Born
Again Santos hater same deal here on the
immigration you notice he will not say a
thing to insult Trump I don't know how
you know in the rest of that clip you my
guess is he stood there when Moscow had
said that and just went right back to
the Border or he maybe even said a
little bit of a defense of trump and
went right back to the Border but he is
in this in this position where if we're
being plainly honest he's [__] all
right he's not gonna he's gonna lose
re-election uh the the courts even
decide the districts have gotten they
they they were even more Republican than
they should have been and he said still
should have never won that seat last
time and he's trying to find that ground
where he can win and pretend you know
that he's not too magish for the his
whatever it is plus three or four or two
Democratic seat he is in a word [__]
so I let him enjoy his attempt to
pretend that he's relevant when it comes
to immigration well watch Moscow would
stuff him in the trash here this is
fantastic mosow is so good sprit for a
second they have been highlighting the
border for a long time okay and we were
late uh we were late to start addressing
it but now that we want to address it
now that we want to lower the amount of
fentanyl coming in now that we want to
deal with uh non-documented folks now
they want to deal with supposed
terrorists potentially coming into the
country now the Republicans controlled
by one man are saying no no no we need
this uh for the next 10 months we need
more of it in fact look at the dude's
face so that we can use it in election
both things are true here this is why
people hate Washington both things it
looks like he's got a fart I'm not gonna
lie he's
like in a Taco Bell fart too you ever
had kind of thing where he's like can't
let it go can't let it go have you ever
have you ever tried to hold in a Taco
Bell fart oh my God it's brutal I can't
remember because a I haven't eaten in
Taco Bell in years and B when I did it
was college and I usually was so drunk
that I I don't know you just let them
loose I I mean I'm gonna tell you on the
on the taco rappers there there is a
there is a surgeon general's warning on
the taco rappers not to hold in the
farts that's that's how severe that's
how serious it is cu you can get inner
Chernobyl right right I mean it's not
it's not a good thing and it looks like
aola like your your organs will right
and you see him here with this face here
this face in this freeze frame looks
like he has let loose because you see
the look on mt's face m is like oh oh my
God and it looks like he's let loose
this Taco Bell for if we see tears
coming down mtz's eyes then we'll
definitely know for sure well let's take
a look things are true the Biden
Administration and Democrats were slow
but now that we're here at the table
Republicans are like no no let's walk
question the question is what is in the
actual bill nobody has actually seen the
bill the bill is dead Donal Donald TR
said you know what's the best part about
this bill and I've been saying this this
bill is actual [__] this bill is not a
good bill it's not most of Republicans
that are I haven't even seen all of it
because I I haven't bothered because I
know it's not going to pass so I don't
care but the if a bunch if a bunch of
Republicans like that like that weener
are for it it then it has to be [__] so
I mean it's you know it can't be any
good it's got to stink worse than the
Taco Bell fart this guy just just let
out for sure right but I do like and
this is where Jared moscowitz is really
good okay I mean this is simple like
rhetoric that you learn in debating and
whatever is you knock your opponent off
by throwing a compliment out first and
you get them to relax and you shive the
[__] out of him he did right there so he
got he got you know old sort of
thornbush face there to to kind of go oh
well as he was holding in his gas and
then boom he like he lowers the boom on
him and the dude's completely not ready
for it and just moscowitz is I'd say one
of you know it's we we've got some good
folks these days but I'd put him in one
of our dozen best communicators
certainly in the house he is he's one of
the he's one of our best well I mean I
mean Moscow it's is is great at carrying
the messaging but he's also great um at
delivering it right you can carry it but
if you deliver it well that is also
Jasmine Crockett is another one that is
very good at at delivering the message
so is Daniel Goldman they good at
delivering the message um and really
honestly the best way they deliver the
message is kind of what you're saying is
they they prepare their opponent to
think I'm gonna make myself a Target
because what happens in in in debate
when you're going back and forth is you
don't want your opponent to Target you
right but if you can get if you can do a
head fake if I can give the basketball
now if you can give a head fake and make
them think you're going you're you're
making yourself a Target their brain
goes oh yeah baby for just a second
y dead yeah go ahead the other one I
like to use is the boxy one the old rope
a doe right you like you bring them in
and then you just freaking nail them
because they think they can come in
close they're getting in there you're
you're guard is down you know whatever
and then you [__] wall up them right
because he really did think that Moscow
it's [__] up when he was like look us
Democrats it we we were late to the
conversation and then when and he was
like yes I got you now [__] here's
going to be all my arguments and then
what moscowitz does because moscowitz
knows I mean these Republicans these
fascists are predictably unpredictable
we all know that and he knews what he
knew what exactly what he was going to
think and what his arguments were going
to be based on Moscow saying we were
late to the game On the Border yeah of
course and so then Moscow it's get just
kills every single one of those
arguments as soon as he says it um which
basically makes him the their opponent
impotent at that point for an argument
which you know half of the the
Republicans are to begin with but well
they are they are I mean yes but here's
the thing like and I'm gonna I'm gonna
explain the the the way you do this by
using two Rocky movies okay you Rope A
Dope which you make him think you're
done and you kind of call him in that's
Rocky four you get the Russian guy he's
all overconfident he's coming in he
thinks he's got it boom you start
nailing him but then you Clubber Lang
his ass which is if you remember rocky3
Mr T which is you get them by surprising
them when they're not ready for it and
then just ripping them a new one you get
them so angry that they lose control of
their emotions and lose control of their
faculties and just you know sputter a
whole bunch of garbage that's Cliff's
Theory write this down of Drago and
Clubber Lang
it's the Drago Clubber Lang Theory I'm
taking credit for it well good well I
just made the [__] up
so well I was I was gonna pivot I was
gonna pivot to impotent Republicans talk
about Clubber Lang okay I want I want to
Pivot to impotent Republicans who don't
carry a message very well I was
wondering if you could tell me what has
the president of Iowa been up to these
days do you know what this uh this guy
running for president of Iowa is up to
these days do you know what he's up to I
think he's got he's at home he's got
he's got a couple of uh um you know sort
of those pink martinis he's got his
booties on and he's playing Abba and
just dancing his ass off that's do you
think his house slippers have heels on
them too because he's so insecure about
his height yeah he's gotta be taller
than his dogs
right his dogs getting to the point
where they think they're taller than him
you know what I think is really funny s
Rhonda santis run against Donald Trump
as for president of Iowa that's what
Ronda Santos was running for um and V
radama dingdong was also running and
they both did the same thing as soon as
they dropped out they endorsed Donald
Trump in their in their in their I
dropped out speech right I was never GNA
be president in the first place speech
right and I support the Cheeto dust q
and honor and they became Cheeto hump
and [__] nuggets immediately in their I
got a Dropout speech not to mention not
to mention the the guy who I think's
broken the record for the most
girlfriends in Niagara Falls Tim Scott
uh who clearly is trying to become vice
president uh I mean have you ever seen a
more blatant ass kissing than than the I
love you and the you know all all that
stuff from Tim Scott like he's just like
he's looking around Tim Scott I thought
you were talking about Uncle Tom Scott
and I know you're talking about Uncle
Tom Scott he's looking around he's like
wait a minute there no black people here
I thought his name was Tom his name is
Tim he looks up in the mirror and he's
like I'm black and and they they want to
pretend they like people like me wait
wait wait I wantan I want to clarify
this Tim Tim it's Tim not Tom I thought
it was literally I thought it was Uncle
Tom Scott I thought that's what his
what's his name you we should speak to
the many many women in the Niagara Falls
area that and is proposing to do you
love I'm sorry do you love that how he
wants to desperately be vice president
so magically he proposes to the
girlfriend we've never seen before on
the beach and you know gets down on his
knees and that's probably after the dude
left and she she comes over and no no no
no his boyfriend's holding the camera
Cliff Jesus Christ someone's got all the
[__] camera someone's got all the
[__] camera Jesus I mean what's the
where would be the odds honestly of
South Carolina having two Republican US
senators
both of whom let's just say haven't
quite convinced me of their passion for
for for the for the sports illustr just
say just say you're on the Tony Michaels
podcast say it clip they closet of gay
in and not only they closeted gayman but
gay gay people in Washington DC will
attest to that glinty Graham is one of
the biggest tender it's been out there
forever right and I still I'm still
careful I don't need these [__]
suing me so I'll say
allegedly but but um I would I would I
would hail the day and I would hold it
up on screen here that lady G would send
me a cease and assist to stop saying
that he's a closeted gay man because I
I'm not saying that I'm just saying
people are saying that exactly their
[__] [__] them people are
saying i' I lived in DC and the DC area
for about eight years and I can say
again Tim Scott I maybe he was a
congressman but no by the time I left
I'm not sure if he was there yet so I I
don't you know never heard anything
about him I will say this lindsy lindsy
Graham's name was tossed out there all
the time with with the other folks the
what was name you know there was Aaron
shck or whatever there was like and all
the other ones who were accused who
people said they saw these things Matt
slapping it you know and whatever ended
up being true in fact I've got something
here that somebody gave me at a
conference which I'll show on air for a
good time call and you got a phone
number this right here folks if you can
see it this is this is toet tapping
Larry Craig somebody made this from
theis
bathroom this to me in a conference so
if you want to pick somebody up in the
Minneapolis have it on my Des for all
time sake so you carry you carry
Republican in a bathroom stall on your
desk um at I don't know what that says
about me but you know nothing else I've
said this show says anything good about
me so Why Stop Now speaking of boots
underneath the bathroom stalls this guy
wears booted heels uh underneath
bathroom stalls I'm sure but he's going
to stop The Invasion into Florida he's
going to send his National Guard to the
to the border of Georgia I'm not really
sure what the [__] is going on
apparently 14 States apparently 14
States 14 Republican Governors are going
to send their National Guard to Texas to
help Texas out and their mission to
secede from the union and fight the
United States military do these [__]
idiots know that the ntion the State
National Guards are part of DOD do they
know this thing right you can do
that George Wallace and send your you
know National Guard there be like this
is the the you know South Carolina this
is the the Iowa this is the whoever
National Guard the minute that Joe Biden
signs the order and federalizes them as
Jack Kennedy did
and others they are now federal troops
wait wait are you saying there is there
is precedent and law on this that that
this is GNA [__] the bed as soon as it
takes off is that what you're saying
you're saying this is all political
theater to get people all riled up I'm
saying it's like every other Shaggy and
Scooby type plan that the Republicans
come up with that always ends up falling
through because they're [__] IDI
performative idiots and they never
intend to actually do anything I don't
know how they think that it's kind of
like attacking Taylor Swift I don't know
how they think this ends up looking good
in the end because in the end if they do
become threatening enough and Joe Biden
sits down and federalizes these guys he
has just emasculated them in front of
like the entire world and like I'm
taking away your troops you're flaccid
now you got nothing Glenn yunin you got
nothing Greg Abbott you got nothing
Ronda santis those are my troops I'm the
commanderin-chief right and and and then
at that particular moment two things
happen you've got the governors and the
and the and the National Guard troops if
any of those folks do not at that point
adhere to Joe Biden's order they are in
open rebellion and they are committing
treason right it's treasonous and
they're not gonna do it they're not
going to do it well I mean this guy
might do it apparently there's a wheelie
a wheelie Nelson concert um down at what
what what do you want from me I'm just
I'm reporting here cliff
I find stuff on the internet and I
report it to the masses and there there
is there is there is there is a there is
a there is a concert apparently going on
down at the a wheelie a wheelie Nelson
concert going on down at the border now
if you've ever heard of wheelie Nelson
you'll know that one of his one of his
greatest hits his mama don't let your
babies grow up to be proud boys mam
don't let babies grow up to be proud
boys I think that's how it goes I think
that's how it goes don't let them go to
New York because they're gonna have a
shitload of trouble with the turn
Styles you saw that but I just did a
whole video on that and added my
commentary uh to to that all I mean that
you could show a hundred times is the
funniest [__] I mean they they literally
like these this is supposed to be the
master race thousands of New Yorkers
philadelphians and Chicagoans and
bostonians and other people four or five
other cities that have subways that are
well used get through those things no
problem every day but this group of dumb
[__] their faces covered you know
couldn't do it could well you know
speaking of dumb [__] that cosplay as
Patriots um and are just nuttier than
squirrel turds to try to gather up and
act like they have a movement have you
seen that there's going to be a new
trucker Convoy there's going to be
there's a new one aren't they going down
to Florida or somewhere like I [__] I
don't know I don't they might be going
to the Florida Georgia border to help
May or maybe they're going to to Texas
well that could be um well I think
they're actually going to Texas here's
the leader of it if you can imagine what
the leader of a of a convoy would look
like this is what it looks like here let
me let me play you this just arrived in
Dripping Springs today the Convoy is
traveling through left out of Baton
Rouge this morning past Houston pulling
in here later this evening all three of
us just a basic assembly tonight go have
dinner together uh tomorrow they're
going to go to the Golden Corral all
four of them Cliff tonight we hit
Cracker Barrel give C reach rounds and
go on and sleep by the
fire we're going well look the mil Team
Six is going to meet down here at the
board mil Team Six meets we're going to
go to Golden Corral we're the Golden
Corral commanders that's what we are
we're going to go to Golden Crow we're
going e Buffet because that's what
Patriots do this is so [__] dumb let
let me show you let me show you how dumb
this is this is [__] hilarious this
is one of the ladies that is join them
um on the this new trucker Convoy um
she's got her own vehicle here for the
Convoy uh listen to what she has to say
call everybody you can tell them what's
happening whether you're here or not you
can be a part of this wait wait is this
is this the pipe bomber um some people
think it's Marjorie Taylor green and I'm
not saying this person is Marjorie
Taylor green or not um it could be
here's all I'm saying yeah that they I
hope there's a warranty for that
wheelchair that thing's doing a lot of
work I know what it is she showed up for
the wheelie Nelson concert let's keep
going I can tell you right now I was a
part of the Convoy yeah from my house as
long as I could until I could get my
truck fixed we need
she she supported a convoy as long as
her truck was running I I I'm telling
you what this gas is getting so
inexpensive that you can drive your
truck for miles and miles and miles
Cliff it's amazing I just can't say I
probably would get in all sorts of
trouble if I said what I really think of
these people but but let's just say the
waste of space you know like I'll never
forget seeing somebody like that I went
to one of these rallies like a I think
it was Trum was it pre Trump it was a
right-wing rally it may have been a gun
rally I may have been doing it for one
of the things I was working on and so it
was right-wing nuts and there's a lady
there there was a lady there like that
in a in know she looked a lot like that
actually in in a like scooter wheelchair
type you know get out like that and she
took off her oxygen mask to eat a pizza
of
pizza I mean was she smoking a
cigarette I was just like I give up on
the human race at that point listen
here's the thing we're not meant to
evolve into anything else we're just not
again like you said um this whole Master
race thing and really honestly the the
sad part is is this lady's stupidity and
her probably what she has is a mental
illness has it's been exploited by the
Republicans and it's been exploited by
right-wing media to convince this person
that she should get on her scooter and
in her pickup truck which it sounds like
she cannot afford to drive many places
and to go down to the border and protect
the Border because no one else will so
really uh in all reality this person is
a victim of their exploitation of her
mental illness more than likely in all
seriousness like and I will try to not
joke for a second what they've done when
and it's it was long before trump it
started with Fox and the NRA you know
sending out these newsletters about
we're going to be attacked and this and
that is they have found a way because
they they they're they're opposite of
what they pretend to be their you know
the little Christian thing we're
Christians they could not care about
their fellow man or woman one [__]
ounce so what they do is theyve found a
way to monetize mental illness that is
what they're doing they are monetizing
people who've got um clinical paranoia
who have you know other sort of
narcissistic and other sorts of
behavioral disorders but particularly
the people with deep seed paranoia and
other problems that in the past would
have had to live with these problems and
would have had difficulties and maybe
would have ended up based on that
hearing the wrong person on TV or radio
or committing crimes or you know what
but they've now gathered them all into
one party into one group and they found
a way to to
monetize this this you know I mean this
disorder and it really is I mean it's
it's gross is what it is there're right
well um someone on YouTube here says um
no Tony they're just dumb they are dumb
this lady they Dum too mutually
exclusive right but they are they are
monetizing not only their Mental Illness
but their stupidity right it's stupid
stupid for profit but listen listen to
the end here where she's trying to
recruit um
keyboard well I mean sort of keyboard
Cowboys here listen keyboard Warriors
okay if you're sitting at home you're on
your phone we want you to be warrior in
for us she wants us to be Warrior you
got be a keyboard Warrior Cliff now come
on out here and join vanilla Isis
oh it's so hilarious but you know they
get these ideas they get these dumb
ideas from dumb people right and and
dumb people when dumb people say things
that sound smart to other dumb people
they think they're the dumb people are
smart and then sometimes a lot of dumb
people elect really stupid people right
like Marjorie Taylor green here um
listen to her talk and get absolutely ah
you just got to watch this is this is
fantastic watch her get owned here let's
talk about border patrol apprehensions
between porch of Entry at the Southwest
border of did she say porch of Entry I
thought we had a wall do we have a porch
is that why is that why all these
rednecks are going down there to because
rednecks love a [__] porch right they
telling you you got some sweet tea and a
rocking
chair I'm telling you Cliff Cliff there
is nothing more that rednecks like than
a [__] porch they [__] love a
goddamn porch I thought at first she was
actually going to say Portugal you know
what country we're in but por was nice
it was a nice touch right right it's the
it's the porch of Entry he more from the
esteemed the esteemed uh What uh she's
the porch Queen she's the porch Queen
here the porch the porch of Entry Queen
let's listen it's so funny um how she
gets dunked on watch this of terrorist
terrorist to say it is pretty rich
hearing the gentleman from Georgia
Express her concern about terrorism when
she literally was selling defund the FBI
t-shirts and hats on her website for $30
a piece $30 for all Cliff when the Griff
gets you oh my god playing that I just
want to hear a little did he say I'm
gonna play the whole thing we're gonna
play it time and time again but this is
when the Griff get you you know what I
mean it really because she was grifting
off the idea that you had to get rid of
the FBI because they were they were
investigating and charging her mango
musolini Jesus but when she wants to get
rid of terrorism doesn't she supposed to
like the main law enfor about terrorism
and then they spend the rest of their
time trying to uh with based on nothing
impeach the head of Homeland Security
right Homeland
Security want to defund the CIA the FBI
the ATF pretty you know why though you
know why though because they want to
make sure to protect actual terrorists
like the domestic
terrorists some terrorists you know
might get investigated too which by the
way she happens to be one considering
she got up on that day January 6th and
was encouraging everybody and has it on
film so we've seen it much like Hamas
she filmed herself well I thought I
thought you were gonna say she's a
terrorist because she knows who the pipe
bomber is I thought that's what you're
gonna say I mean I don't know I don't
know if she knows I have no idea but
some people say that she knows who it is
exactly some people say thing you're no
I'm I'm serious some people are saying
on the internet that they say it
everywhere that Marjorie Taylor green
definitely knows exactly what shoes the
pipe bomber was wearing what kind of
underwear that the walk yeah right she
probably knows she probably knows where
they got rid of the hoodie that the pipe
bomber was wearing I'm just saying I
think she knows this information now I'm
not saying she knows it because she is
the pipe bomber I think it came to her
during one of her tantric sessions in
the gym but you know what to me be that
as it may what you had to say there Tony
um what we do know is she was saying the
1776 stuff standing Out Among the group
of people and encouraging them to rise
up on January 6th and I still for the
life of me do not understand how she
hasn't been arrested for sedition like I
don't I I guess I don't I'm not a lawyer
so I don't but I just there are some of
them where we kind of know that they
were
involved then there's people that are on
the on
video you know encouraging people to
attack the you know the capital I just I
don't understand how she she's not in
prison I don't get it see Lisa here on
YouTube she says she's the pipe bomber
so people are saying that saying some
people people are saying what am I
supposed to do I I you have to repeat it
it would be irresponsible of you when
some people are are sharing this
information what am I
supposed I am just supposed to put the
information out there and everyone is
supposed to you know believe whatever
they want to believe whether it's true
or not I you know I'm just free speech
man right it's freedom of speech because
that's what Russell Brand and Glenn
Greenwald say must be true those people
are saying that too people are saying
that too that we should just say
whatever dumb stuff comes to our mind
and people will believe it they're
saying that here speaking of dumb stuff
let's watch this whole clip back it's
fantastic watch this let's talk about
border patrol apprehensions between
porch of Entry at the Southwest border
of terrorist terrorist and I have to say
it is pretty rich hearing the gentleman
from Georgia Express her concern about
terrorism when she literally was selling
defund the FBI t-shirts and hats on her
website for $330 a piece $30 for the
shirts and another $30 for the hats you
don't get both for just the $30 the
leading law enforcement agency tasked
with combating terrorism in this country
and keeping people safe and she wants to
defund it so I not going to take any
lectures from her on securing this
Homeland from Terror and with that I you
back that was awesome who was that by
the way I have no idea but he did a man
magnificent job um and Democrats are
getting better and better at this I want
to point out something I do have to say
quickly that if our our Port of Entry
really is a porch of Entry yeah well no
wonder so many people are getting in I
mean we just we just put a porch up
there exactly can we can we get can we
get the laboratory to get us a live shot
of the porch of Entry because we really
need to see what is going on down there
at the porch of entry on the border but
you know I this is not the United States
border did you know that it's not the
United States border it's the border of
terrorists listen entry at the Southwest
border of terrorist the Southwest border
of terrorist it's not the United States
of America border it's it's it's the
port of inur it's like the People's
Republic of China this the
Southwest oh my God oh my God
I mean did you see she had to look down
just to read four multi-c words in a row
like she she
just she said she said she said the
porch of
injury at the Southwest border of
terrorist you do you get to sit on the
rocking share of Freedom if you come
in
oh my God she's so stupid it's funny I
can't I just can't like she every time
she talks the dumbest well Lauren
bobbert gives her a run for her money
but my God those
two in the Southwest border of
terrorists I'm getting you know what $30
a t-shirt I'm making that
T-shirt and you know what folks and hat
you get
$60 each 50 for
both I give you a
bargain you know the best part about
this whole
thing this this is the opponents of
democracy God these are the
people these are the people that are
trying to overthrow our democracy sticky
Bandits because if they had like even a
half dozen brain cells to rub together
there'd be danger
out oh my God this is the person who you
know she doesn't know to I mean we go
into all her many misspellings Marshall
and Marshall and principal and princip I
mean know don't forget the peach tree
dish that's right she is and the the
the the gapo police man can you imagine
how different it all be if somehow her
husband had found a way he had money man
maybe he could have like cryo freezed
her or something like that so we
never damn house and like everything
would be different you know what um I'm
going to say this and I know this is
gonna be very unpopular but um I'm
actually glad that having her there I
actually I'm glad that Marjorie Taylor
green um is gets elected in some [__]
eater District in Georgia and the reason
why is because uh she's a huge
fundraiser for them that's the only
reason why she exists in the first place
um is because she fundraises on hate
white Christian nationalism um that's
that's how she does it that's why they
love her because she gets she gets
[__] bigoted white racist all [__]
fired up to to hate brown people and to
hate black people and to hate the city
Folk and hate the border and hate
foreigners and all that [__] hate
the lgbtq community hate trans children
um that's what they love about her best
and really honestly um I'm glad that she
is dumb as [__] because if if if we if
we were in a situ situation where
margorie Taylor green was a smooth
political operator we would be in big
trouble here no it's a lot more that
would be a lot more dangerous and again
or even the ones that are smarter you
know someone like Ronda Sanchez who's
smart but is a meatball and like has no
personality whatsoever Tom Cotton who
like literally is where Charisma goes to
die you know those two are smarter what
we're lucky is we haven't had the
combination yet of somebody that I'm
aware of who's smart uh smart enough and
evil enough and has those two two
qualities together um because that's
dangerous but I'm not aware of any of
them that combine those two so let's
just hope that that doesn't come along
because that's where it gets really
dangerous you said something about Tom
Cotton and his bigotry did you catch the
other day that Tom Cotton um looked at
an as looked at an Asian man he's like
so you're Chinese right like no I'm I'm
notes no you're Chinese right what was
the show um that took place in the South
the cartoon like the um with Bobby the
little son and the dad who's like come
on I can't think of the name of it
somebody in helped me out in the uh
comment
section it's it was made by the guys who
made The Simpsons and I can't think of
the name of it but it was the cartoon
there's bobb's the kid he's got the like
the king in the hill thank you I
couldn't think of the name and there's
when he meets his
neighbor the first time he's like are
you Chinese or are you Japanese he's
like ocean are you he's like so are you
Chinese or are you Japanese he's like
I'm La ocean he's like what
ocean that's basically Tom Cotton here
if you no well let me let me show it
here so everyone can see um it's it's a
Fant I'm sure we're gonna laugh as hard
at this clip as we are at Marjorie
Taylor's green porch of entry on the
Southwest border of terrorists
but uh let's let's go with with Tom
Cotton and how he thinks every person
who is from Asia is
Chinese of what nation are you a citizen
Singapore are you a citizen of any other
Nation no zenor have you ever applied
for Chinese citizenship Senator I sered
my nation in Singapore no I did not do
you have a Singaporean passport yes and
I served my military for two and a half
years in sing do you have any other do
you have any other passports from any
other Nation
your wife is an American citizen your
children are American citizens that's
correct have you ever applied for
American citizenship Chinese or Japan no
not
yet or are you Chinese or Japanese there
it is see that's what happens here on
the JY Michaels podcast you say
something we deliver we got it we got it
on hand here um at the we eventually
accuse him of being like a Chinese
Communist Party member and he's like I'm
not Chinese for well well I mean oh oh
oh I thought you meant on King of the
Hill you meant you meant
you mean you meant the king of the
[__] here here let me play you king
of the [__] here Mr Mr K is there
not a more perfect racist name than Tom
cottona like like Tom Cotton the
probably probably more closeted of a gay
man US senator than Lindsey Graham yes
I'm gonna say it I'll say it out loud
people are saying Tom Cotton's gay
that's what I said people are saying it
and I'm one of them and I'm saying it
right now and Tom Cotton's a CLA of the
gay man but uh Tom Cotton here it
couldn't get more racist I I almost bet
he changed his name you know what I mean
he's like what all appeal in Arkansas
right like like what what could possibly
be the most racist name he wanted to
change it to Tom slavery but it was
taken right he had to with cotton Tom
Toms slavery gmail.com was taken so he
had to go with Tom Cotton all right
let's let's see if Tom Cotton uh let's
let's watch his racism on display here
okay
okay have you ever been a member of the
Chinese Communist Party Singapore no
have you ever been Associated or
affiliated with the Chinese Communist
party no Senator again I'm Singaporean
let me ask yeah but you look
Chinese suspiciously like the members of
the Chinese party to me from
Arkansas my God what the [__] listen you
have stupidity in the house right you
got stupidity in the Senate I mean
really is just a stupidity [__] show up
there with the Republican GOP in
Washington DC isn't it combination of of
it is idiocy mental illness and racism
varying amounts and and that's your your
witches brew that gives you a Republican
these days yeah now you've met a lot of
staffers on the hill okay and you
probably talked to many Senate staffers
now if if so people at home can
understand House Seats attract career
staffers because there are career
staffers in Washington DC and they bring
some of their own people with them but
they staff a lot of their offices with
people who are career staffers and they
kind of move around from Congress person
to Congress person but a US senate seat
is different it is it is a different
type of Staff it's a different type of
political office it is a different type
of um just it's different than the House
of Representatives so when you have a
staff on in the US Senate they're
typically more career more serious um
they've been there for a while and they
plan on being there for a while tell
tell the folks how how ridiculous it is
that this kind of questioning worked its
way through not only to Tom Cotton but
through staff members to for Tom Cotton
to ask because he had these written down
he was reading these [__] questions
it ain't like he was just uh improvising
these right first I want to make sure
that my stupid camera stop making me
[__] like oh yeah you're all blurry
you were drunk as [__] happen like twice
what the I don't know I paid a lot for
that [__] thing
um is that is that is that camera from
China or Singapore I don't know is your
camera
Chinese have you ever been part of the
party the Chinese are you is this is
this camera part of the Chinese
Communist party oh my god well the
Senate is different in that you know you
were talking about the Senate versus the
house yeah so many Senate I mean like
it's the biggest joke in Washington and
almost every Senator wakes up in the
morning looks in the mirror and sees a
president you're right away Staffing
yourself often with with with people
been loyal to you forever because you're
expecting that you're you're going to
either be on a presidential or a vice
presidential campaign uh and that's what
makes it somewhat different than the
house so uh in terms of who wrote those
questions for him my guess is is that
nobody was probably I mean I don't know
maybe there's some lunatic he could have
easily some white nationalist idiots
working for himas he definitely has
white nationalist sure I'm sure he does
but like ones that are stupid enough to
actually write those specific questions
or you know he could he could have just
been like because he clearly has mental
issues himself uh could could you know
he could have barfed them up normally
you would rely on your staff and you
would have a professional staff this was
in the old days um but now there's you
know the mag of Republican Wing which in
the Senate's got to be worth at least
two-thirds of them and probably somewhat
more are not they're not professionals
they're people that used to be image
advisers in Tennessee and you know so I
mean who's advising them people just as
stupid as they are that's what you did
the image advisor ever look in the
mirror do do they do image advisors is
it that should be like part of their
licensing processes they have to oh you
want oh you want to be an image advisor
in our state okay well there's licensing
process the first step is to look in the
mirror at your own image exactly make
sure your image is not utterly
ridiculous yeah so I mean I I mean who
knows what what happened there but I get
the feeling that dude is is I could give
you something easy to run with if you
want Tony and just say that dude has a
bug up his ass go ahead make your joke I
know it's coming
um I mean he is he is an angry have you
ever seen him smile like he is just
consistently this I didn't think he had
that upgrade I didn't think he actually
had that upgrade no they didn't they
didn't put that upgrade that might be in
the new Elon brain chip the Tom Cotton
smiling upgrade might be in the new the
new Elon by the way I don't want to
change the topic but when I read that
somebody had tried it like you watched
what this guy's done with Twitter and
like and like exploding rockets and
Tesla [__] you put on like the left
blinker and it blows up and whatever the
hell else and you said yeah I think I'll
have that in my brain well these are the
same people though that were going to
boycott the NFL and never watch a
football game again because Colin
Kaepernick took a knee and now they're
bitching about Taylor Swift showing up
at a football game because she's [__]
the tight end like these are the same
exact people are like oh the fiser
vaccine's got a chip in it oh elon's got
a brain chip yeah I'll put that [__] in
put that in there right and they only of
course how would they know Taylor
Swift's there because they're still
watching the N right right right it's
the same people these are all the same
bucking people that's what they are and
they all look and act like Tom Cotton
here ask you some hopefully simple
questions you said earlier in response
to your question that what happened at
tenan Square in June of 1989 was a
massive protest anything else happen in
tenan square yes I think it's well
documented there was a massacre there
was the indiscriminate Slaughter of
hundreds or thousands of Chinese
citizens why is he telling this guy this
he's like I'm not Chinese exactly by why
are you it's a whole different place
it's in Southeast Asia it's here wait
wait is it on the is there a Southwest
border of terrorism and porches of
Entry that's it to China through the
porch of Entry that's what it was on the
Southwest border Singapore border of of
terrorists what is wrong with these
[__] people man how are these people
elected people in positions of power I
don't know but I'm happy because we get
to make such good content I mean imagine
imagine how boring this [__] would be
without these stupid [__] Rubes I
mean think about that is a very good
point if any of these people were
competent more difficult time finding
what to talk about I mean it's so easy
to [__] with these people at this point
I mean it really truly is the thing is
is like you have to do it and you have
to kind of make sure you talk about each
of them because there's two or three of
these things a day right the margerie
Taylor green one the the Tom Cotton one
like you'll if you if you take a day off
and you're sick you'll miss like three
of them right like of them and then you
have to double up and do six of them
right I do I do two hours every day and
I can't get to all the [__] let's
check in at the porch of Entry here um
with the on the wheelie Nelson concert
um here at the uh Southwest border of of
terrorist uh it looks like it's going
really well there I don't know his hair
his hair is very inviting to that at
that particular porch of Entry so oh my
God the porch of [__] entry at the
Southwest border of
terrorist can't make this [__] up man no
you can't make this [__] up I mean she
can and then we can mock it and make fun
of it well yeah I mean they make up [__]
all the time but I you know half of it
is I don't even know they may actually
think that they know what they're
talking about all right well yeah well
let's get serious about those borders
thing because um for just for just like
30 seconds here very T
because porch out
of I can't get the image of margorie
Taylor green sitting with with in a
rocking chair with wheelie Nelson
sitting next to her uh with their big
AR15s ready at the Southwest border of
of
terrorists you can't make this [__] up
um but here's the
thing
this this border thing is actually try
to not laugh go ahead right this border
thing is actually a bunch of hooey right
and Democrats have messaged this thing
poorly for a long time for decades and
decades they poorly message this where
they buy into the right-wing messaging
that the imaginary line that people
cross is somehow the problem the
imaginary line whether it's in the
Southwest border of terrorist or the
Northwest border of Canucks right um it
it really really that's not the problem
the imaginary line is not the problem
people crossing it is not the problem
it's how we treat them when we they get
here right and those policies that we
have in place on how we treat them when
we get here um people not willing to
consider the changes of those policies
that's the actual problem yes it's not
the policies themselves really because
we know right now that the Republicans
are in a a hot mess because that Donald
Trump wants them uh to meech apparently
are impeach tree dish I guess that's
what it is imp Peach Tree dish um
mayorcas the the the secretary of the
border right he's the secretary of the
Border it's the only thing that he's
really responsible for I that's all he
does right he just does that just the
border so he the secretary of the Border
they want to impeach tree dish him um
even though the Senate is the ones
trying to get the bill and then they'll
have to vote to Adam out of office it
doesn't make any sense really it makes
about as much sense as having a porch of
Entry instead of a port but but here's
the thing is that the messaging has
always been lost on this and the Dems
have dropped the ball on this for so
long so I actually appreciate that
moscowitz even though he was setting up
a debate
um a false Target in a debate there yeah
I actually I actually like that he's
admitting that because I've been saying
that for the last two weeks as
everyone's been yelling and screaming
about the Border as if it's a big
problem the imaginary line it's not a
problem it's how we treat the people
when they get here but really it's
Washington DC that's been the problem
for the long time and I believe that if
Democrats would have would switch their
messaging to the problem is the bigots
who won't let us fix the [__]
policies that we have that's what it
should be to assimilate people into the
American Experience repeating that which
is hey guess what we have a bill here
and again it may not be the greatest
bill I don't know oh it's complete [__]
it's complete [__] right we have a bill
right here and they're blocking they
won't let us do it just just pull out uh
like an offensive maneuver on them
Counterattack and go after all of them
and go on every show and write every
oped and do everything possible be like
why won't you let us pass this Mike
Johnson why won't you let us pass this
Mike Johnson stop monitoring your son's
porn and let's pass this you know and
and and and and you know I don't know
maybe his son has good porn I don't know
maybe that's maybe he can balance both
at the same time right he's like
monitoring the porn writing the Bill I
don't know just know that in the end
that they should change their messaging
I agree with you that that you know this
whole the borders of disaster is you
know we absolutely need to change how
people are treated how they become
citizens you all these things that that
need to be done how businesses are
treated that are obviously trying to
bring people in and pay them under their
table and not pay them enough and
exploit them but the the the thing is
we've had numerous opportunities to do
this every time Republicans have stopped
it from going through over the last 10
12 years to at least improve things
somewhat right and so the the giving in
to the oh the border is a mess I mean
look Republicans deny climate change and
that's an actual real problem when they
want to just deny something exists they
deny it whereas we sit there and play on
their game when they're making something
up every time they should every time if
we had messag us correctly from the
beginning it would have been like the
the whatever On the Border like I don't
know what you're talking about there's
not a disaster on the border there a
couple policy issues we need to change
them we need to get better stop blocking
us from doing that or we need we need to
welcome these people into our country to
grow our economy and make make America
great again if you want to say it that
way I don't give you can say it a number
of ways but you know you Counterattack
you do it your way but instead because
we've admitted so many times said oh it
is a disaster we we can't sort of back
out of that now so the best way to
handle it is the way Jared moso is which
is we got late to this we weren't here
but now we're here what are you doing
right you know and that's that's
probably the best way to go with now
well and and not only that it it really
because they're going to pick Donald
Trump as their nominee and his one
talking point is that brown people are
going to come rape you and kill you and
and they're all you know they're Caravan
that's on its way right and I'm gonna
take a thing from mind confidence say
poisoning the blood of America I'm gonna
steal that Hitler quote and but I didn't
say it the same way because I didn't say
it in German um I said it in English
instead of German so I said it
differently okay but right but but
that's the one thing he has left because
he cannot they know that they're going
to lose on on Roy Wade they're going to
absolutely lose on again you know this
is now a month old or two months old but
a lot of exit polling again pretty much
only polling I trust surveys and that
kind of thing has shown that the
Republican share of the vote has
declined on average by seven points
since
dobs think about that for a second and
how much that is remember that's the
reason Lauren bobert besides the fact
that she also is an idiot and pisses
people off and whatever had to run away
from a plus six Republican District I
mean part of it's because she's so awful
right a republican that ran that knew
how to run a good race can hold on to a
seat like that but but it means that
really anything up to a plus seven
Republican seat is in play you know what
I mean and so it's worth you know and
probably if if it's a bad candidate like
Lauren bobert you're getting into who
loses extra points because they suck
you're getting to the plus 10 plus 12
Republican range right so I mean these
are there's no doubt that you know
they're they're hoping that somehow this
this border garbage can can bring them
back that's well and I think the the
best thing that happened here was Joe
Biden pretended that he would sign this
bill and I'm gonna say that out loud um
because I think Joe Biden probably at
the end of the day he would probably
force himself to sign this bill because
he basically said look I don't care what
the bill is I'll sign the bill and the
reason why he did it is to call their
[__] Bluff yeah knew it was a he knew
it was [__] I don't I don't know
your your [__] camera is on uh I
don't know it must be uh must be trying
to zoom in something by mistake at least
it hasn't right it hasn't been this way
most of the show no uhuh no it's it's
it's only um every once in a while when
the camera's like Cliff sounds like a
[__] idiot and needs to shut up it
blurs me right well let's check in um
down there at the Port of Entry on the
will Willie Nelson it looks like they've
changed um it must be picking up steam
down there from the Convoy it looks like
Willie Nelson has now traded in rocking
chair on the porch of Entry that is this
is his chair on the porch of Entry here
it looks like he's the uh he's the will
wheelie chair Commando now um down there
at the porch porch of entry on the
Southwest border of terrorism I just
want to check in there with with Captain
every time I think I drag stuff to the
lowest common denominator wait wait wait
wait I have more work to do apparently
I'm mistaken I am mistaken this is not
this is not wheie Nelson this is Captain
Greg Abbott of the 101st chairborne
division um it is theun verse chairborne
division here so I'm sorry I don't want
to misspeak you know I only bring the
facts here Cliff I I'm not here to fool
people aren't you I know that and that's
what I appreciate about
you I did I did piss people off because
I found a video of um of Taylor Swift
endorsing dark Brandon they got really
mad at me for posting it they said it
was fake I don't know I don't know if
it's fake or not um what we need to do
though dude seriously because you were
reading out those Twitter accounts they
need to get like a joint event Lady Gaga
Katie Perry and Taylor Swift all of whom
in their politics they've spoken out are
all very liberal and get all I mean I'm
sure there's overlap there but still
those three accounts if you had them
stand up and all do a joint endorsement
at the same time that would light the
media on fire well here's one that kind
of lit a lot of liberals were really mad
at me about posting this video that I
found and I'm not I'm not really sure
where I found it just happened to pop up
on people are right well people are
saying that I that this may have be AI I
don't know but you can decide see if you
can spot if this is real or if this is
AI hey swifties it's Taylor here I just
want to let you know that I am
officially endorsing dark Brandon for
president of the United States [__] that
other drug riddle fat slob I I I don't
know I think this is pretty authentic to
yeah I mean I would think if she
endorsed that would be the way she'd do
it right right I don't see any lie there
I don't see any lie there nothing
nothing she said in there whether it was
her or AI right but I'm sure it was her
uh you know whatever nothing I saw heard
her saying there was an untruth no I
don't think so I mean I don't believe so
it doesn't seem like it to me but I want
I want to give the audience a sense cu a
lot of people were mad at me that I post
that they're like Tony take this down I
think one person actually said you
should really take this down and I think
my response was let me see it was you
should really [__] right off I think
that's exactly what I
said could not see you
responding that you know what's
hilarious is when people come and
they're like Tony Michaels the [__] them
guy like literally that's the thing that
I got at the top of my Twitter I've had
up there for a long time I'm known for
telling people [__] them and they're
like I'm
well I want to show you here because um
this is serious right now the reason why
I mean this as serious is that they're
going to weaponize Ai and what I mean by
they are going to weaponize AI Nazis
okay these these Cheeto humping [__]
nuggets these white Christian
nationalists are going to
weaponize
AI against democracy 100% they are going
to use this thing now clip I I I I've
never been in the military I've never
been in the military uh I know some
folks that hav been but I watched a lot
of second world war documentaries and it
feels like to me Hitler used tanks and
the US wasn't like you know what we're
not going to use tanks because the Nazis
use tanks that's something you know we
just it must tanks must be bad because
Nazis are using well the British
invented them so they were an ally and I
almost feel like I know where you're
headed with this analogy so you go ahead
well so here is here is an example of uh
some AI here now this says Republican
victory in 2024 depends on their being
able to do this now you see here there's
some black people here um talking to
each other on on porches I don't know if
this is at the porch of Entry or is this
just a regular no this is just this just
a regular p no no no I don't think this
is that porch but I wish it were but
here you see they have the the Maga what
appears to be a m hat on but if you look
really closely over here at this
gentleman right here he has three arms
here um I'm not sure what the hell's
going on down there at the porch of
Entry impressive work but uh but this
guy's got three arms now this guy is so
dedicated to life he grew another arm
right well I mean you know he he's
keeping America great Again by getting
as many arms as he possibly can in the
fight right I mean they said all hands
on deck and he's like should grow more
hands then the guy who shared that by
the way Patrick gini is a jack off who
well I mean I mean we could go into that
go ahe holster who I ran into in the
he's just he's a he's a little weasel so
I guess what I'm asking is depends on
their being able to do what what is he
getting at fake that black people like
them I mean what well I mean that's
that's exactly what he's getting at is
he's trying to because here's what I
want to tell you okay because I come
from rule White America and there is
nothing more comfort comforting to rule
white bigoted racist ass people than
than than a black person who also think
that that white people are superior so
it must be right you know yeah right I
mean that that is the thing that gets
gets bigoted ass white people going more
than anything is a black person who
hates black people as much as they do
and thinks that white people are more
Superior and that's the one thing that
gets the juices flowing with these
[__] Nazis that's what they're doing
why the Republicans Trot out all sorts
of sort of tokens whether it's you know
women who are anti Choice whether it's
blacks who love Trump Jews who love
Trump gays who love Trump you know
whatever like because they they make
their own people feel like see I'm not
bigoted that gay dude over there likes
Trump too exactly well and and that's
their excuse to be the worst version of
themselves and I mean it maybe that that
gay dude is Lindsey Graham I'm not
saying because it's allegedly of course
no no definitely is because people are
saying that's what it it's he definitely
listen you cannot be sued for defamation
with truth so I would love to see
Lindsey Graham's tender tender app um so
if he wants to challenge me if he wants
to send me a CN D let's let's have at it
Lindsay let's do it he's gay your
[__] grer the one oh it's grinder
that's it that's it see I don't I don't
know I don't know I'm not on the [__]
dating ass grinder that's it it it's
that is it so Lindsay if you want to
send me a seege and assist if you're
really mad about defaming you um because
I'm just saying what people are saying
that you're gay then I'm going to
subpoena your grinder app uh all all the
data from your grinder app that's what I
want so just know if you send me a seas
and assist that's what I'll be looking
for and I'm not saying he is but if Tim
Scott were gay right then oh my God
you've got like a double minority right
what else do you need from that guy
you've got it all Tim no you you're
saying it right it's Uncle Tom Scott
it's Uncle Tom Scott Cliff Jesus I I
thought we established
this but here here is here is a bunch of
racist ass [__] coming up with
AI because this this is the blacks for
Trump you remember the the t-shirts
blacks blacks were Trump here let me
normally you would see white people
wearing them which was the most well let
me let me show you um I'll show you what
this means the blacks for Trump I bet I
can pull it up very quickly here um
blacks for Trump actually before we go
here because we only got a few minutes
blacks for Trump I'm going to show you
what this means what it originally was
um if I can find the [__] picture
here come on blacks for Trump and I
rolled the dice it's like some old white
people come on you gotta be able to find
it I I well I know it's like two old old
white folks um that are blacks for Trump
I've actually seen about three different
pictures of a couple old white weing it
right well and I I was actually going to
say the reason why um the the reason why
it's blacks for Trump is because it's
it's Cletus and Ethel black that's their
name they're they're the blacks they're
the blacks the blacks for Trump yeah I'm
trying to find it too I'm not doing very
well yet yeah well I I kind of [__] the
bit on that oh here it is here we go
here we go here's here's here's Cletus
and Ethel black um and they're the
blacks they're the black family is that
actually true is that their name or you
just making it up I wouldn't I me make
stuff up are you kidding me no but I can
the kind of I could totally see
Republicans doing being like my last
name is black so you know what I mean
like the blacks for Trump I mean I
totally wouldn't make stuff up Cliff I
promise but of course you
would is it's funny either way I'm
asking if that is actually their last
name no I I don't know I just I mean I I
I could see how that would work though
like you said Republicans I can see them
reaching out to every Maga supporter
whose last name is black and sending
those t-shirts shirts to them so they'd
wear them around like that's the kind of
[__] they would pull well or they
would take AI videos to try to fool
racist white people and they're thinking
that blacks support Trump by having
three armed Goro style you know who Goro
is with the Mortal Kombat Goro style AI
here um and and folks that's the reason
why we have to use AI to mock them is
because they're going to weaponize AI to
actually convince people to do horrible
things and make horrible decisions here
and cliff so people don't make horrible
decisions tell them where they can
follow you and watch your videos so they
can be
enlightened Enlighten you yeah you must
come over to at C Shor that's the place
on YouTube Tony uh sent a lot of traffic
lately because he's a good man and uh so
so of some other great folks and we've
got videos every day we don't do the
live stuff although we may at some point
but commentaries three to five to seven
minutes me ripping the [__] out of
people and so and I grab clips from
interview like this and we have fun come
on by subscribe you like go go follow
Cliff everywhere no matter where it's at
matter what put in the comments here
yeah throw it in the comments there give
them the link just uh go to sector on
YouTube follow his YouTube channel
you'll see our Clips there too and you
if you follow the Tony Michaels podcast
you'll see some of those clips Clon only
like hey I clipped your show and I'm
like I'm G to put it on the community
tab so I throw it up on the community
tab get to see uh double the fun double
the pleasure double the fun but not
three armed type fun not three armed and
none of it's taking place on a porch of
Entry so that's oh my God the porch of
Entry please tell me you're going to cut
that clip please tell me that's that's
going on the uh The Cutting Room floor
the porch of Entry I mean you don't want
me to use that no I want you to I want
that okay unless you're saing I'm G no
I'm gonna clip it I'm gonna clip it you
should clip it I'm not going to use a
Margery t green clip where she gets made
to be a fool and you and I laugh at her
uncontrollably we can't stop laughing
that's just about the best clip I can
think of from from this so far although
the Tom Cotton one's pretty solid too it
is pretty solid you might consider that
one as well Cliff Sher thanks for
joining us and thank you to the audience
as you're here every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific for two full hours
doing nothing but mocking and [__]
with these fascists so that we could win
in 202 don't forget polls don't [__]
vote polls don't vote people do don't
trust the polls trust your action use
your strategic outrage to engage in your
democracy one good way is to come here
every single weekday for two full hours
and to get in on the mockery with
nothing but [__] same time same place
tomorrow Surfs Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast podast in your
face commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them
Murphy's muor head ass
speaking no longer the wet Bandits we're
the sticky
Bandits let's talk about border patrol
apprehensions between porch of Entry at
the Southwest border of terrorist
terrorist and I have to say it is pretty
rich hearing the gentleman from Georgia
Express her concern about terrorism when
she literally was selling defund the FBI
t-shirts and hats on her website for $30
a piece $30 for the shirts and another
$30 for the hats you don't get both for
just the $30 the leading law enforcement
agency tasked with combating terrorism
in this country and keeping people safe
and she wants to defund it so I am not
going to take any lectures from her on
securing this Homeland from Terror and
with that I Y back oh
sorry